experts at Johns Hopkins University say
more than 79 thousand people worldwide
who contracted the corona virus have
recovered that's good news this morning
we're hearing some of their stories our
dr. taryn irulu is outside Lenox Hill
Hospital in New York City where five
coronavirus patients have been treated
Tara normally you'd be here at the table
but we're all practicing social
distancing but we always want to hear
from you so what are you hearing from
people who've been diagnosed yes so
we're hearing a variety of symptoms
coming from the people diagnosed ranging
from fever to dry cough and shortness of
breath and everybody you're about to
meet is also sharing their story of
recovery
excuse me but it feels like hell I've
had the flu before it's it's not even
comparable the fever is so high that you
hallucinate a.n preferred we only used
her initials she described about with
kovin 19 that's lasted for more than two
weeks I'm still having but it's coming
down slowly I'm only at about a hundred
point eight at the moment which is a
dramatic improvement initially treated
at a Seattle area hospital in early
March she was not offered a test for
kovat 19 but says the medical staff were
concerned I could see them through the
window when they were preparing to come
in and they were utterly panicked and
they had no idea what they were doing it
was unnerving to be completely honest
from home a and Isle Din to a telehealth
appointment and was promptly told to
report to a clinic where she was swabbed
in her vehicle and confirmed for Kovan
19 in under 24 hours it was like a
weight off my shoulders honestly it was
like I'm not crazy across the country
and still hospitalized in Rome Georgia
clay Bentley used a baseball analogy to
describe his current state of health
he says symptoms developed a day after
singing with his church choir two weeks
ago diagnosed with pneumonia at a local
hospital the next day he was sent home
the corn I couldn't get out of bed I'm
said I feel like y'all sittin home to
die and I said I can't even harder live
and I can't breathe back at the hospital
he discovered several members of his
church were there too I have since found
out that there were other people and in
choir this in the hospital now with
coronavirus now in recovery he credits
faith and family this has made my family
very close okay you know they can't wait
for me to come home so but we're gonna
have he will have a celebration that
feeling of isolation is a shared
experience of the corona virus survivors
who spoke with us Elizabeth Schneider
believes she and a number of her friends
contracted corona virus while at a party
in Seattle she tested for kovat 19 after
her symptoms had subsided with a
background in molecular biology and
through her own experience she shared
some advice for the anxious if you look
at the long term here I think things
will improve things will get better they
probably will get a little bit worse
before they get better but things will
improve life will go on
98% of people who are diagnosed with
coronavirus will survive and some
survivors like Elizabeth Schneider who
you heard about are actually paying it
forward she's donating her blood to
science so researchers can see if that
blood can help provide a future
treatment or even a vaccine Wow that's
nice to hear I got to say Terra is it as
unsettling as it is to hear the details
I actually think it's helpful yeah
because you start don't you fine guys
everything that happens I go is this it
is this it is this it so the more
details we hear the better so Terra what
treatments are available now well it's
interesting so scientists are looking at
a lot of different types of treatments
HIV medications flu drugs drugs that
treat rheumatoid arthritis and even
chloroquine which is a very old drug
that we used to treat malaria but the
most promising candidate is a drug
called REM desapear it's being studied
both in China and the United States and
clinical trials it is an antiviral that
blocks the replication of the virus it's
so interesting Terra what a broad range
of symptoms these patients have all had
yes an important also some people are
reporting GI or gastrointestinal
symptoms so it definitely can present in
a variety of different ways but most
often the fever cough and shortness of
breath all right you know one thing they
keep saying Anthony is to take your
temperature and I've been doing that and
my temperature the other day was 88.9 I
thought God the cap was on the thing